I'm determined to ask you a safe
question about secret Invasion
oftentimes when we look at a big
franchise like that we consider the
production process to be like the Marvel
machine yes you now have hands-on
experience producing and really taking
time with a smaller film like this is
there anything about the production
process of that machine that came as a
pleasant surprise something that
creatively you didn't think you'd be
able to pursue but you were surprised
that you got the opportunity to do it is
mind-boggling I gotta tell you the
Marvel the way the way that those shows
and films are created is mind-boggling
like it's it's like it's like everyone
at Marvel knows how to unlock the
Rubik's Cube and you couldn't even
possibly I can't do a Rubik's Cube to
save my damn life I think a lot of
people I hope a lot of people can't also
but there's just some it's like they
have some secret thing and it just what
it just works and I've tried I've tried
to understand it and I've tried to be
like okay logically how is this how do
you guys what's their
it just they there's something they're
drinking some water over there I don't
know what it is it's fabulous it's maybe
made of money a bad bottle of water that
they're making right yes we can sell
that no no they just think they nail it
they just absolutely nail it and they I
mean I'm not the only actor to say that
that working with them is is just kind
of brilliant
it really is we had it we had a lot of
laughs big part of the reason why I'm
always a fan of that franchisor here I
see the best things on the screen and I
hear the best things behind the scenes
they're just so chill and I think I'm
not that chill and I think if I were
them I would be so untrilled all the
time and they're not they're like yeah